luego de tres semanas bajo completo
control talibán la vida sigue con muchas
incertidumbres en afganistán
que dios nos ayude en el futuro no
sabemos cómo va a ir el país eeuu está
interfiriendo china está interfiriendo
francia está interfiriendo la manera
como todo el mundo se está entrometiendo
en afganistán abre la posibilidad a que
estalle una guerra
de la normalización de las relaciones
internacionales y del reconocimiento del
nuevo gobierno afgano depende en gran
parte de la futura economía del país
donde la ayuda al desarrollo representa
un 22 por ciento del ingreso general
nacional según el banco mundial
afganistán es una tierra abundante en
recursos naturales especialmente en
minería sin embargo la riqueza de su
explotación está lejos de llegar a toda
la ciudadanía entre otras cosas por la
inestabilidad y la corrupción
la situación de seguridad es buena
estamos contentos de que ya no haya
robos pero espero que la situación
económica mejore necesitamos que este
aumento de precios para algunos miembros
de los talibanes abusan de su poder
hacen una especie de discriminación
racial nos cuestionan sobre nuestra ropa
y nuestra barba no preguntan a los
pastunes solo los que hablan pero son
distintos portavoces occidentales
declararon estar preocupados por las
vulneraciones de los derechos humanos de
la población por parte de los talibanes
particularmente de los de las mujeres
distintos analistas señalan que lo que
realmente importa la comunidad
internacional es la cooperación con
kabul en la lucha contra el
autodenominado estado islámico y la
estabilidad en las regiones las mujeres
afganas están a su suerte y como han
demostrado estos últimos días son
perfectamente conscientes de ello